there is a lot of finger pointing going
on as the block faces this unprecedented
energy crisis that winter crunch is
looming and according to some this is a
problem that has been years in the
making let's have a look at some of the
main issues across europe at the moment
and we'll start here in france where
there has been a price increase this
month of 12.6
in gas tariffs that follows several
months of other rises the prime minister
jean castech says there will not be a
freeze and there will not be any more
increases but of course that doesn't
mitigate the months of increases that
people have already seen on their
household bills then in spain where
prices there have tripled in the last
year i mean we know that the spanish
government has made emergency measures
to try and mitigate the worst impact
from the poor but small business unions
are just saying this is an impossible
situation coming after the coveted
crisis businesses just cannot take any
more
and then in italy where prices are set
to soar by 40 percent the italian
government has announced a package of
three billion euros to try and aid that
and then in germany we also heard last
week that one power plant had to
completely shut up shop and it's not the
first time it had to also do the same a
number of times in september why well
because it couldn't get enough coal this
crisis when it comes to natural gas has
pushed more people towards buying coal
depleting those stocks as well so it
seems like this is a double whammy so
what's behind this looming catastrophe
well the eu cannot agree on that but
some member states see that this is a
problem the eu has caused itself because
it's pushed too fast too quickly to move
to greener energy and at the same time
has moved away from fossil fuels and
essentially what it's done is has left
the entire block exposed energy prices
are currently soaring across the eu and
putting unprecedented pressure on both
energy companies and on our citizens
when designing energy and climate
policies we have to ensure their social
acceptability otherwise we risk their
failure well the eu flatly denies this
it rejects it it says actually this
crisis shows that the problem is that
there is too much dependence in the eu
on fossil fuels and the reality is that
the only way to mitigate crises like
this in the future is to move harder and
faster towards green energy instead of
being paralyzed or slowing things down
because of the price hike now in the
energy sector we should speed things up
in the transition to renewable energy so
that affordable renewable energy becomes
available for everyone well as the eu is
scratching its head over what to do it's
also looking potentially for a scapegoat
and some have suggested that russia is
to blame for this crisis saying that it
is holding back on natural gas reserves
russia says that's not the case in fact
russia says it's willing to step up to
the hour of need of its european
neighbors and increase the supplies of
gas to meet those needs those demands
but what needs to happen for that to
take place is the certification of the
nordstream 2 pipe this is a pipe that
was completed last month and would see
natural gas be able to be delivered
directly to germany but before that can
happen that certification needs to take
place that is something that eu finance
ministers are likely to discuss this
week as they meet to discuss this entire
crisis but the idea that eu finance
ministers are discussing bread and
butter subjects like energy bills and
how people are going to pay them really
gives you a sense of how deep this
crisis is and as they're scratching
their heads looking for a solution there
are tens of millions of households who
are concerned about what this winter is
going to bring the difficult choices
that they will have to make in order to
either heat their homes or feed their
families all the while the eu is
wondering how it will keep the lights on